in uh in 2012 you went to the doctor
he's even interesting diagnoses what was
the diagnosis I was diagnosed with
Bipolar
- uh which is its manic depressive type
thing and so that was it was part of a
lot of my problems which what it
basically is as I have ups and downs in
the downs lasts for a couple of weeks
and it really was remarkable I was
getting anything done because when
you're in a depressive state you really
don't have any energy or motivation in
some cases I was really sleeping I was
literally sleeping for about 14 hours
out of the day and you feels so lazy but
it's and the thing is when you feel so
lazy you get depressed and then all you
want to do is sleep and so you get you
know and so it's it becomes a spiral and
so yeah I really I mean you just know
something is wrong and then but you feel
ashamed you know you don't want to do
anything about it and so that's where it
really gets me a problem is when you
start feeling shame about it and that's
unfortunately we live in a society where
we attach shame to something like
depression or bipolar or any kind of
psychological problem because we brand
them as lazy or stupid or or we
misunderstand it but yeah we just we
kind of say something like snap out of
it works or yeah we say something like
when it comes to suicide as we bring
them as cowards or something like that
not understanding that it's more than
that
not just we just don't understand it
where it's not a matter of willpower
it's it's an illness and so it's it's
not a matter of success or wealth or
something like that it means I got
looking at Robin Williams I had
everything and Chris Farley you know
something like that
it didn't matter you know it was a
matter of treatment and a matter of you
know social circle and and friends and
stuff like that it's a matter of
reaching out and diagnosis and stuff
like that there's a lot of factors at
play here and now more than ever I think
I really hope those people in those
incidents bring it to life that if you
have a problem where if you feel that
you're going through something that
isn't normal
that you need to you need to reach out
and you need to at least kind of seek
treatments or at least talk to a doctor
and just just not even a psychiatrist
necessarily like if you see a doctor or
something like that
just tell them what's going on and say
that this doesn't seem normal to me you
know and that's enough and they'll tell
you if it's normal or not it's probably
not lots people lots of people have kept
these problems and that's the biggest
problem is is that we attached shame to
it you know and that's it's hard to
admit that and there's nothing to be
ashamed about no it's not your fault
your fault and that's the worst part of
it if people think it's their fault or
that you can just snap out of it you can
in nine you can't do it on your own
sometimes you need friends and you need
treatment and that's that I think that's
the biggest myth is that you can just
stab yourself out of it or that you're a
coward something like that
there was a point I have never had
depression before but there was a play
my life where I realized I actually knew
more people with depression than without
and I was trying to get an idea of what
it was like and I'm never there there
was one there was one moment of time
where I knew things were okay at my mind
would but I didn't feel it and I didn't
understand why these two were not
showing up doesn't like everything to
feel like a great job everything fine I
think was shortly after to publicly
actually house or seems like maybe a
little bit of a failure because my guy I
know I kept people up for so long and if
he were really have a hard time getting
through it I saw that and and I think
because of the
I really felt like while I let so many
people down even though I knew like it
got done it got finish and it's okay
you're gonna make something great uh but
I just was not feeling it and so what
what I always hear is that it doesn't
matter if you know that things are okay
yeah don't feel it that's where things
don't film that's where yeah tragedy
yeah it in the case of like depression
or any kind of in that kind of mental
illness and I'm not saying that's what
you have rationally rationally it
doesn't matter you can know things are
fine but if that's not the problem you
can't stop the waiting but that's you
can't stop the way that's weight feeling
it's you know what I mean it's like okay
I know everything's fine I know I'm
doing great like financially and
emotionally or not emotional a bit you
know in my situation I know everything's
fine but I can't get up you know I've
got anything done today why I can't get
in front of the camera today yeah I feel
like crap you know and then that people
say like just get up get over it and
you're like well now I feel worse
because you tell me I'm lazy
you're telling me uh you tell me get
over I can't you know and that's that
it's it's it spirals and it doesn't help
you know what I mean you know that's
that's the worst thing you can do is to
tell people just to get over it it's
this pussy you know Lee because people
say that so if does it
how much better their and so in your
case it was you were under so much
pressure and things weren't going right
you know I mean you had C we're juggling
so many actors in so many egos and you
had you were you were you had such time
constraints hey I think you were burned
out oh sure I am yeah I I didn't want to
give other thing you know you know I
have depression well no I wouldn't know
if I've know I know I know Ben you know
but but yeah but certainly the idea the
same direct yeah that these two things
that usually go together are not going
together and you think they would always
go hand-in-hand but they don't know but
yeah in that case I think you were just
almost like almost like post-traumatic
stress like you were in a bad place like
but yeah it's it's that same impact
we're like rationally you knew that you
had done this great thing but you were
Freud you know and so you needed rest
you needed to just stop for a long time
I think maybe and maybe people didn't
understand that but yeah it's a lot of
times anyway there's been a lot of we've
lost a lot of people this year you've
definitely said to people who have
depression what's the best thing to do
and what's the best way to go about it
for those who don't have it what they
feel is the best way to help people we
wish and I think the best way is to
mainly understand what I've been talking
about is to is to understand that it's
not a matter like like I said it's it's
not a matter of willpower it's it's an
illness and it's not something they can
just snap out it's a matter of
understanding so when they tell you you
know when they tell you what's going on
and that well that that's the thing is
they may not necessarily tell you what's
going on but if they understand that
especially in the case of leg comedians
and stuff like that because you noticed
a lot of comedians who are having
probably that's a lot of times
put up a front because that's the only
way they know how to deal with something
a lot of times their way of coping with
something is they'll they'll try to like
push it away to reject you understand
when somebody is trying to kind of call
out for help
um and you can tell you know I mean you
can tell and just make yourself
available you don't need to force
yourself Oh like you don't need to have
an intervention no need to kick down the
door me like I'm trying to help you you
know you don't need to have them
committed or something like that but
just knowing that somebody cares
somebody is willing to pick up the phone
that's big no I think that's a lot it's
a lot of problems as though they feel
like they don't have anybody to call mmm
there's a time doing the time I was
talking about where I felt anymore
people with depression then I said I
have a bad habit of we what you were
talking about bursting down the door you
need help I was kind of a person for a
bit with some people and I was thought
it wasn't best route to do and what
somebody told me I want to know if you
felt sore the same way he said the best
way to look is look at very much if
someone falls over a ship or a boat what
do you do you don't dive in after him
you throw a life preserver and they but
they have to grab it cuz if you were to
dive in and save them you could drown
with them you know but you throw the
life preserver they grab it as you pull
them in what would you read that yeah
wait yeah just just just if you see
someone in a rough place just be like
hey man are you okay that's it that's it
you know and if they say not really
that's pretty much how they'll say it's
that you know there
things we always see and we see online -
so many times where somebody can just
say something I can just be like just
the smallest thing that can be like just
a dagger and really Debbie in the heart
but there's so many times where someone
can say just the nicest little thing
that can really count with your spirits
- yeah but really people people turn a
blind eye to it or they're afraid to
you'll you'll see it something I think
everyone's guilty of this you know
you'll see signs of it and you just kind
of ignore because you don't want to deal
with it it's cowardly but like all you
have to do is just ask like okay that's
it some things and from there it's up to
that person to say yes or no because you
have to one help you get to accept it
but you can't force it you know and
that's really it's that's that's the
two-step process and so you can't blame
you can't blame you know I I couldn't
blame you and I couldn't you can't lay
blame on me for not accepting the help
but that's I had to realize that you
know what was going on and I had to go
ask for help but that's that's the key
like then every interview with the two
polar opposite questions here one of
them you may have just answered but
let's let's go ahead and try it uh what
is the toughest thing you had to do
weather professionally personally and
most importanly how'd you get through
putting all that aside let me try to
answer that on a different few issues
huh shooting the crossover movies was
arduous but I wouldn't have traded it
for the world
kay Cassie was amazing we I've never run
that much in my life over more typical
three but I'm not complaining that was
amazingly cool I got to see stranger
things that I've ever seen in my life I
saw Molossia which was great I don't
want the only people not to walk away
from that injured which was you
any of the places you would have thought
I would have been crippled it would have
been kick-ass you did injure yourself on
our front porch remember I did which
again was one of the more difficult
experiences when I destroyed my foot on
your front porch but I tell people I
kicked someone so hard in the ass I
broke my foot ah okay everyone the
audience Shh let it get out
suburban nights was incredibly difficult
because of the bad weather circumstances
forced us to shoot everything in like
three days we had a week three days
amazing shoot the love that love that so
boldly flee yeah all across from the
videos were just incredible but very
difficult shoots because we had we were
essentially shooting movies which take
two three weeks in three days but really
great working with so many talented
people how did we overcome them it's
because I think we all clicked so well
together
really remarkable how how well how fast
friends we became and how much that
helped us overcome it um yeah I know
that sounds maybe like I'm copping up
but not it's I think I'm really proud of
the end result of that and we really
overcame a lot of difficulties on the
spot you know you especially overcame a
lot of a lot of difficulty when it came
to having like this gigantic script and
then on the spot having such
difficulties on set and then paring it
down and still coming up with I mean you
have so many characters to juggle and
being able to still give everyone their
moments and making a fantastic series of
videos I'm very proud of all so yeah
area but again the might answer my next
question here final a final question
again with a professional or personally
what is the proudest thing you've ever
done
proudest things represent hmm Capote
Leafly is really stands out is one of
the coolest things I've ever done
mainly cuz I've been a lot nah though
rarely as yourself yeah I've always said
I've always said to boldly flee has that
I'm in almost all of it and I'm in
almost none of it
spoo Deus is not in that movie really I
get sealed in a cardboard box and then
I'm just kind of done but the Ultima
series that I'm really very proud of
that and the Final Fantasy tens he
really worked out well for me
um I'm just really proud of I've come so
far you know that people are so
supportive and so so passionate I mean I
would not have seen myself here ever you
know had I started this out like I said
this was the completely accidental
I'm not accidental but like unforeseen
it strange what hobbies can we do
yeah right I mean this like I said this
started office like just a fan video you
know and it completely failed I had I
had a blue robot that still to this day
just sits there cuz I had nothing to do
with it of the sleep he's like be icon
he's still next to your title and
everything yeah and it's like just he's
there and only oh so like this I just
put him in a video and you're just like
why is that thing there I'm like I don't
know so but yeah I'm just it's it's
amazing that people people watch you
know and they find me funny enough to
they they want to keep watching and they
want to hear what I have to say and I'm
very proud of that I'm very proud that
I've managed to entertain people this
this long that I've managed to learn so
much about you know about about you're
making it just
I've managed to learn you know and then
grow - wonderful
this has been Noah ant why aware this
was shut up a talk
thank you good night now this is where
we alligator and we talk to Gerry devote
views and get a fly over you not gonna
get real Perseus just laughs is the most
sour cream I've ever ingested it once it
up oh my god right and with the pancakes
for older the Sheep oh that's great
he was wearing his class rings oh yeah
helmet made and everybody goes through
that right but Taco Bell yep they put
seatbelts on the toilets there I know